on est bien peu de chose et mon amie la
rose me l'a dit ce matin à new moore je
suis né baptisé de rente ai
je me suis épanoui
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre nouvel
épisode du petit émir la semaine
dernière nous avons commencé à voir le
portrait de marica afin de découvrir le
métier d'art thérapeute l'avion et c'est
au centre et lindor de sainte suzanne
lors des répétitions de danse avec ses
élèves c'est là que nous la retrouvons
on
oh
et
après cette séance riche en émotions
emmanuel l'une des aides
médico-psychologiques nous explique que
son travail et celui de marica je suis
aide médico psychologique ça fait à peu
près dix ans que je travaille au centre
d'éducation motrice avec mary kay ce
cher jean intervient auprès des enfants
polyhandicapés donc des tout petits 2
3 à 10 ans en fait mon métier
dans le relationnel
dans l'éducatif principalement avec eux
ces jeunes je connaissais pas le métier
d'art thérapeute gelé découvert en
commençant à travailler au son du
ducation de maîtrise il n'est pas connue
essentiellement à la réunion et c'est un
métier qui permet aux enfants qui ont un
handicap ou en difficulté quelconque de
pouvoir se revaloriser de pouvoir
avancer et de pouvoir faire face aux
difficultés qu'ils ont et par le biais
de l'art ça peut être le dessin ça peut
être le clown cela peut être la danse
c'est le chant aussi ils peuvent
s'épanouir en fait
marica elle est très carré donc elle
elle en demande beaucoup en fait être
quasiment professionnels dollars c'est
que nous on met pas mais dans un sens en
fait ça nous permet aussi de se booster
et puis d'avoir énormément de peps pour
les spectacles américaine je suis super
heureuse de travailler avec toi et de
faire cesser ateliers et j'espère qu'on
va continuer
c'est maintenant l'heure du repas un pic
dit que rapide prix en compagnie des
élèves dans les jardins du centre
l'horloge tourne
il est temps pour marika de foncer
récupérer mathias au centre masse de
sainte suzanne
c'est l'occasion pour marika de nous en
dire un peu plus sur elle même et sur
son métier mois de formation je suis
comédienne j'ai fait le conservatoire et
d'autres formations et ensuite après
d'autres domaines et bat g
j'ai fait un des ud art thérapie avec la
faculté de médecine de tours eh ben j'ai
commencé au cm avec des enfants
déficients mode
et maintenant je suis avec tout public
l'art thérapie
c'est une discipline paramédical donc
c'est déjà un métier je suis
art-thérapeute depuis 2003 et
c'est développer le potentiel artistique
personnes vers dans un but thérapeutique
donc on peut faire autant de là
du chant de l'ess des arts plastiques du
théâtre
pour essayer qu'il soit mieux dans leur
peau et qu'il soit surtout à qu'ils
arrivent à s'exprimer
moi j'ai
depuis tout petit je fais de la danse
j'ai fait du théâtre après au collège au
lycée et bon voilà et après quand j'ai
eu 21 ans j'ai eu une maladie assez
grave et j'ai vu l'envers du décor c'est
à dire le côté patients le côté maladie
et j'ai eu envie aussi de voilà de
redonner sa à d'autres personnes je
pense que ça vient de là aussi c'est
donnant-donnant qu à un moment donné on
dit dans notre vie bon quoi le théâtre
c'est bien les arts plastiques c'est
bien mais comment leur transmettre
comment leur donner
marica arrive maintenant au centre de la
ressource où tout le monde attend pour
commencer les répétitions nous laissons
toute la troupe pour cette séance de
répétition et décidons d'aller
interviewer le fils de marica qui se
trouve au même moment au skate park de
saint denis afin qu'il nous livre ses
impressions
on aide les gens
moi si j'étais handicapé je serais
content d'avoir une personne qui
comptait et faire des animations
je suis très fier du métier de maman car
pour elle c'est très important car elle
est passionnée et que ça c'est utile
pour les gens pour les parents les
sommes des gens les enfants handicapés
et bien voilà vous en savez désormais un
peu plus sur marica et son métier d'art
thérapeute
la semaine prochaine nous vous proposons
d'assister à la rencontre entre la
troupe et des musiciens orientaux
à très bientôt
on